[Music]
[Applause]
Jeff passen of the mothership ESPN
senior Baseball Insider joins us on the
program explained to me the procedure
not surgery that show hey Otani had
surgery uh
they tried
to around it essentially to not use
the words Tommy John
what it was uh reading between the lines
here was a revision reconstruction with
an internal brace what that means is
Tommy John's surgery has evolved through
the years right it used to be then the
original procedure uh Dr Frank job went
into Tommy John's elbow and drilled
holes and essentially looped a new uh
UCL through those holes using a tendon
that was taken from his wrist from what
Neil elatrosh the Doctor Who did the
surgery said in the statement he talked
about it being a repair and a
reinforcement which suggests that they
didn't go in with a brand new tendon and
loop it through that they reinforced the
old one that was there and added an
internal brace which is something that
Dr Keith Meister uh noted Tommy on
Expert has been doing the last few years
and that Neil elektrash has picked up on
as well and that has found a ton of
success in keeping guys healthy
essentially though yes this was Tommy
John surgery and show hey otani's not
going to pitch next year and the chances
of him coming back and pitching in the
future frankly are pretty good
okay what's it do for his leverage here
in the off season
not a whole lot because he's still hurt
right like that's the problem with this
I I was so genuinely wanting to see him
go into this winter healthy just to see
how high his contract was going to go I
think if he was fully healthy going in
it was going to be 650 million dollars
so I think that this UCL tear that this
procedure is going to cost him 150
million probably but I I really don't
foresee many scenarios where it gets too
far under 500. like maybe maybe teams
are hesitant but let's look at it this
way Dan you have a baseline in place
already with Aaron judge to whom shohei
Otani is a very comparable bat right you
have nine years and 360 million dollars
that is a recent comparable you also
have the fact that shohei Otani is the
biggest star in the sport and
international superstar that your
franchise value just by having him
around is going to jump you're going to
sell tickets you're going to sell
merchandise you're going to sell
concessions you're going to sell
everything and then oh by the way you've
got the pitching element too and while
you may not necessarily want to go out
and guarantee that type of money Jameson
tion is a two-time Tommy John guy who
went out and got 68 million dollars from
the Cubs this past offseason and shohei
Otani is a lot better than Jameson tion
has ever been before so I think the
argument in his favor to go and get that
500 million really is valid it's just a
question of which organization and
specifically which owner is going to be
willing to take that leap because all
the other ones then are going to want to
say you know what yeah we'll we'll look
at you being a pitcher but you're gonna
have to earn that this is going to be
incentive based and frankly I don't
think he's going to want it to be and I
don't think he should have it need to be
should I read into the fact that it was
the Dodgers surgeon who did the surgery
on shoheiotani now Neil alatrosh is just
excellent at his job he's the guy he got
him and Meister are the guys you go to
and you know Jeff Dugas in Birmingham
like the David all check like there
there are certain surgeons but when you
are on the west coast and you live in LA
you go to Neil al-atras simple as that
when do negotiations start for show hey
oh Tony
the day after the World Series ends
and you know what I'm sure there's back
channeling going on right now uh that
that probably is uh against rules and
regulations but uh even with this
surgery Dan he's still going to be the
you know the the hottest free agent that
we've seen since
Alex Rodriguez the first time when he
signed with Texas like I I can't think
of another player who's gone out there
and uh retrie agency I mean Bryce Harper
but that that free agency sort of
collapsed on itself uh and and that that
to me is going to be the defining
question here
um are teams going to use the UCL issue
as an excuse to avoid going after a
Transcendent player or are they not
going to get in their own way and say
this is a once in a lifetime literally
Dan a once in a lifetime guy and we have
the opportunity to get him purely for
money we don't have to give up players
we don't have to give up prospects all
this is going to take is money and I
think the smart owners out there will
approach it that way and we're going to
see a pretty interesting free agency on
account of that all right give me the
teams
one through three that you think uh are
going to be tough to be or they're going
to be in for the sweepstakes here
can I can I go more than that because I
I don't I haven't like I don't think
there's an established favorite at this
point I think coming into this season
the expectation was Dodgers or busts I
don't think that's the case anymore uh
like around the industry the Dodgers
certainly have interest in ohtani and
they're certainly going to be there and
if they ended up uh with him in their
uniform next year it wouldn't surprise
me
um but the Dodgers are going to be there
I think the Boston Red Sox are going to
be there I think the Chicago Cubs are
going to be there I think the Texas
Rangers are going to be there San
Francisco Giants
um you know a team like Seattle is
really interesting to me what is
Seattle's appetite going to be to go for
the years rather than that short-term
high dollar contract and I don't know if
it's gonna play out this way necessarily
again but it would not surprise me at
all if a couple teams early on jump in
with offers for like four years at 200
for 40 million dollars you know just
saying hey we're not going to go long
term with you but we will give you you
know 50 more than any player has ever
made if we will make you a 60 million
dollar a year player and at that point
is ohtani going to be intrigued by that
or is that simply going to embolden him
to take that 60 million dollar a year
number and try and get it for eight or
nine or ten years as opposed to the four
or five that some teams might want to
might want to offer the Angels odds did
they move at all increase decrease with
the injury that he had
I guess maybe increased slightly because
there's a chance that the market just
collapses right there's a chance that
teams look at this and say
I you know we thought he was a 60
million dollar year player but now
there's just too much uncertainty and
the angels could swoop in but I gotta be
honest I'm not sure that that the angels
are are willing to go out there and
spend the money to resign him I don't
know I don't know how heavy the interest
is going to be there could they have
traded it almost two months ago I know
that we said that they should have but
yes of course of course they should have
I mean it was I I wrote this in my my
column on espn.com yesterday it was
giving out Awards and the biggest
blunder goes to the Los Angeles Angels
for not doing what was patently obvious
to everybody not named Artie Moreno and
when you have an impetuous owner who uh
makes decisions flying by the seat of
his pads and suddenly like five days
before the trade deadline when you have
good offers lined up for a guy by who in
all likelihood is going to leave but if
you hold on to him all you're going to
get out of it is like the 70th pick in
the draft is compensation and you say
you know what
we're fighting for a wild card spot and
that sounds like a damn good idea I mean
it's malpractice then it is and then I I
mean of course they're gonna Double Down
On It by going out and getting Lucas
gioleto and Ronaldo Lopez that day and
then a month later they give those guys
away for free I mean it's just
organizational
incompetence that I frankly don't blame
the baseball operations people for
because they're just doing what their
owner asks it's just extremely poor
ownership simple as that always great to
talk to you Jeff thank you for joining
us
pleasure is always mine Dan thanks buddy
Jeff pass Mothership ESPN senior
Baseball Insider